normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government here's
a story from op India Washington Post
and BBC falsely claimed the Dublin
attacker was not an immigrant here is
the truth I love this they got they got
community noted The Washington Post
tweets online rumors claimed the
perpetrator of a stabbing attack was an
immigrant the BBC found the man was an
Irish citizen who had lived in the
country for 20 years police blamed a
lunatic faction driven by a farri
ideology for the riot in Dublin and then
uh here's the fact check the man is
indeed an immigrant as he was originally
from Algeria The Washington Post segment
appears to conflate citizenship with
being with not being an immigrant and
you can be both that's amazing so are
they blaming this on the far right are
they saying that he was far right well
so uh Carl Benjamin actually tweeted out
something an anecdote where someone said
an old lady was me talking about you
know Ireland a guy mentioned going to
Ireland she said did you hear about the
riots he said no and the woman said it
was something having the the far right
uh stabbed someone or something like
that this is what the media wants to
happen yeah that's why they're lying
about this person being an immigrant
they're TR this is it activists I think
it's simply put many of these media
organizations have activists who work
there the reason why the mainstream
corporate press is claiming that GE
Wilders and other politicians are far
right is because they are actually far
left if the major majority of the
population is voting for a dude then
that's the median mhm right or not
necessarily the median but that is the
plurality or the majority that is where
most of people see their views so that's
not far anything that is right leaning
right but it seems far to them because
they think they are the truth over here
on the super far left and the middle
doesn't seem they lie cheat and steal
and this is another element of it it's
it's it's laughable it was clearly an
immigrant who did this we can argue
whether or not this single anecdote is
is ex uh uh exemplifies the entire issue
of immigration I don't think so I think
it's a data point but I do think people
are right to be upset when their
government refuses to listen to them and
then the media lies just like this to
trick people and some people fall for it
well then you have to put the far right
moner on it so that then you can justify
the censorship and everything else
that's going to come as a result we had
the the woman in the Irish Parliament uh
was that recently uh talking about
taking away your rights it was in June
yeah yeah you have your rights well now
you got Conor McGregor being
investigated for saying we're at War
which by the way that's happening here
that's happening here in the United
States Douglas Mackey is locked up over
a tweet you know from 20 uh 2016 my
co-host on Badlands on sitre he had the
FBI raid his house three weeks after
January 6th over a tweet he was not in
DC on January 6th was his tweet we we
are at War this is and the the worst
part is in the warrant if you look too I
it was like a thread if you look two
tweets up he says we're in an
information war and he because they they
isolated that one tweet and said we're
in a war rolled up with Bearcats and up
armored vehicles at 6:00 a.m. to wake up
the whole neighborhood threw a flashbang
out there went into his house raided his
house found that he uh you know they
they took whatever they want the FBI
then they called in the the the local St
uh sheriff and they arrested him because
he had a gun safe with an AR-15 in it he
was a
cop he was a cop in California but
because he was I I think he was like
temporarily suspended while there was an
investigation I guess he wasn't techn
technically supposed to have that so he
was arrested and he's still fighting
them to this day that's insane yes over
a tweet yeah that happens in the UK all
the time like moms have been
investigated or arrested handcuffed in
front of their kids for having posted
that women aren't men that's happened
repeatedly you've had a situation
recently where a British guy
um had posted a video talking about all
the Palestinian Flags like up and down
the High Street and saying that he
doesn't like it and police showed up and
in and they dragged him off in handcuffs
and you had uh you know people screaming
out to the neighbors they're they're
taking him they're taking him in for a
tweet they're taking him in because he
doesn't like the flags down the block
that's just Madness where was that that
was in the UK that was in London that
was in London um you know that they had
they've had all those protests and there
were all these palestin he posted a
video on Facebook that was like what is
all this doing here what about Tommy
Robinson do you guys see what happened
to him over the over the past weekend he
got arrested for no reason he's sitting
in a cafe eating breakfast and they come
and they say you have to leave or or or
else and and and it's actually funny
because he basically says okay pay for
my breakfast and they go no and I'm like
I actually kind of think that's a
reasonable position he should not have
to leave Tommy should be like bro you're
going to have to arrest me and he and
and he kind of did say that but then
eventually he goes okay pay me back for
my breakfast and I'm like like he's
essentially saying fine I'll leave give
me my money back and they're like we
won't do it they won't even do that I
did think it was funny that in the end
Tommy was actually being reasonable to
their demands when he didn't have to be
but they said you are what what do they
say that you're causing har you're the
potential for alarm or distress yeah so
therefore you're not he's he's in London
and they said by order of the city of
London which is I believe it's separate
from London to some degree it's like in
the middle and it's got different police
or something and uh they're like you
have to leave or else and it was an
anti-Semitism March and the police
arrested him and pepper sprayed him
while he was sitting in a restaurant
waiting for his breakfast well and the
articles that came out about it
indicated that he was anti-semitic and
he was at the
March like opposing anti-Semitism
covering it and there were some 50 cops
or whatever surrounding him to get him
out of there meanwhile like there's been
vandalism there's been people climbing
up on statues there's been all kinds of
mayhem and those people are just let to
go by you know let's let's talk about
how they're going after the memes so
Nate Nate Hawkman tweets the hate speech
law that Ireland is preparing to pass is
arguably the most radical legislation of
its kind we've seen in the west it
criminalizes the mere possession of
materials that quote are likely to
incite violence or hatred books videos
or even memes on your phone look at this
this is amazing offense of preparing or
possessing material likely to incite
violence or hatred against persons on
account of their protected character
eristics they say let's see a subject to
subject blah blah blah A person shall be
guilty prepares or possess material that
is likely to incite violence or hatred
against a person or group or person on
account of their protected Char
characteristics or any of those
characteristics with a view to the
material being communicated to the
public or a section of the public
whether by himself or himself blah blah
blah prepares or pres such material with
intent to inight violence we get it we
get it you get it being Reckless as to
whether such violence or hatred is is
thereby incited yes they're basically
saying memes if you uh theoretically
if you have Netflix on your phone I'm
sorry Dave Chappelle made race racial
jokes and for
that you're under arrest I mean this is
it this is I
like part of me is actually excited for
this I'll be honest because the line can
only go so far until it goes off the
edge and then there's no line anymore so
they keep pushing and pushing and
pushing and then it's gone and
everyone's just standing around like
okay there's no rules anymore for
instance like this uh for instance
basically is saying if you have on your
phone a video of Dave Chappelle doing
his his his stand up routine where he
makes fun of Chinese people well that's
it you're going to jail but this is
Netflix this is like
mainstream International top tier comedy
not doesn't matter in New York they just
banned discrimination they signed into
law discrimination on the basis of
weight and height you know this means
insane yeah this means that a 600 pound
morbidly obese person can apply to be uh
you know to work for a government
position or let's say Starbucks
Starbucks and then they let's say they
apply online then the Starbucks says
come in for an interview well that
person can't move of their own power so
they have a crane bring them to the
Starbucks and they can't get in the
building and then they say this is
discrimination based on my weight and
height that I cannot enter the building
for the interview so Starbucks all these
businesses are going to have to tear
they're going have to remodel all their
stores to have double doors to
accommodate the massive and morbidly
obese the only goes so far until it
falls off the edge when we look back at
architecture it's going to be a crazy
time that's when the double doors come
back I mean this is such a disturbing
way of phrasing it because this idea of
likely to incite violence or Hast is
determined by the government so what
does the government decide is likely
like there are all kinds of things I
don't like that I'm sure the government
is for and so we know there's
automatically a double standard for for
what materials are okay and what aren't
all that really matters is culture it
you know when we we have the first
amendment in this country you would
still be arrested for obscenity so like
George Carlin for instance this this the
seven words you can't say on TV he gets
arrested for it yeah so even though we
have the First Amendment back then it
didn't matter our culture did not allow
it regardless of what the Constitution
said so we talk a lot about the
Constitution and the rights at
guarantees but let's be honest they
didn't really guarantee a whole lot
until we started enforcing them and
having the Court's rule to enshrine
these protections and set this precedent
so when we're looking at these banss all
that really matters the government will
decide whether or not you go to jail
that's it they're basically the law
should say we as the government can
decide to arrest you for any reason and
lock up if we want that's basically what
the law says did you see that in the in
the fat in the no more discriminating
against fat people in New York the
person who bought brought the uh the
bill sha Abu was inspired to bring the
bill because he gained weight during
covid and thought people looked at him
weird after no really no yes what's his
what's his what so he sued the
government on what standing he didn't Su
the he brought the bill he's a city
council he was inspired to bring the
bill after gaining weight during the
pandemic and noticing people didn't
treat him the same afterwards and he
said it's also about changing the
culture and how we think about weight
when it was um hilarious yeah when it
was uh brought up before city council
and people were arguing in favor for of
it uh an NYU student said the desks were
too small and this was a reason to not
discriminate how much weight did this
guy gain I need to know well I was
looking for pictures of him and he looks
pretty normal the bill of course was
backed by the National Association to
Advance fat acceptance and the chair of
thatou that in this country right the
chair of that group said this is such a
powerful moment for anyone who has ever
faced discrimination simply because of
the size of their body someone else said
that they felt pressured to develop an
eating disorder and so this was a reason
to bring the is that the same thing as
dieting I don't have any idea didn't New
York pass a law or or attempt to pass a
law like I don't know probably seven or
eight years ago Banning like certain
size beverages like you couldn't get
that was Bloomberg yeah more Super how
we go how did we go from that to now
where we're at with this that's just a
the soda company Sue to be like no
that's discrimination against the size
of our cups you can't do that here well
and also you had Michelle Obama was very
like pro- Fitness and now isn't she just
ableist well I mean the pro- fitness was
like giving kids like high fructose like
just loaded down like grape sodas and
stuff well drinks uh juice that was
loaded with sugar I mean it was it was
it was pretty awful yeah the funny thing
too is Eric Adams who backed this bill
about you know no discriminating against
fat people he's vegan and he he pushed a
plant ba based diet in New York City
schools for Fridays all the there's no
like meat in Fridays and my son would be
like cuz we used to live in Brooklyn and
my son would be like oh it's Friday it's
going to be terrible lunch today there's
no meat in school on Fridays yeah it was
like a it was a vegan thing Eric Adams
was pushing a plant-based diet it's
Catholic school we did that right I'm
like this a Catholic thing no it wasn't
it was an Eric Adams thing for a while
they were pushing a lot of P places
pushed meatless Mondays because they're
saying if you eat less meat it's good
for the environment and whatever else
but Eric Adams is like sort of an
evangelist uh he's a super vegan
evangelist evangelist diabet he he had
some very serious health concern was
like this Chang he wrote a whole book
about how he lost 35 entire pounds 3
well but he shouldn't brag about that he
had me disorder it's different
he's got his plate pretty full right now
Eric Adams now the the boomerang of his
bill that they used to get go after
Donald Trump they it literally
boomeranged on the very last day I think
it was came back at him and I mean that
guy's just in a world million dollars on
that they're investigating him over uh
you know allegations he took bad money
from Turkey the thing about the turkey
though is he was heading down to DC to
give Biden what for on immigration and
he literally had to turn that asella
around and head back to New York because
his campaign person her home was raided
by the FBI you know I I don't think that
that was a coincidence Eric Adams who is
both has angered the Biden
Administration by saying we need help
and angered every bur around him by
busing migrants to them right thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8: p.m. and become a
member over at
timcast.net shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time